I went on too long because you guys did
quite well in it it's a textbook
question basically distinguish between
the role of the human expert and the
knowledge engineer in the development of
this expert system now you guys did so
on this I reckon we can just quickly
rehearse the what what's what's the
human experts role here it's the human
experts role especially with a relation
to all of this yes right this is the
expert who then the person who's just
decided after you know decades of giving
security license of people and
withholding security licenses from
people those these are the kinds of
things you ought to you want to know
about someone before you give them a
license right excuse me you know for
instance you can picture this this
person before they are an expert then
excuse me hey did you guys see them
alright so they might have had a
different set of questions for instance
they might have not looked for valid
documents that have been you know to
actually put your eyes on it right so
they're looking for the Australian
resident and I've just said yeah if
someone says I'm Australia resident sure
you just trust them but then after you
know a few years doing this people say
yeah I'm an Australian resident cuz I
know that's what you have to be to get a
security license and then you know later
on you're fine there a little bit
illegal if we go to something like that
you know Teddy habits like no they're
not gonna let that happen so anyway he's
realized okay it's an important
condition i should add this year right
so the human expert is the person who
was realized after a long time and
experience and wisdom this is a good set
of rules that i should use to judge
whether someone ought to get a license
or not okay so that's the human experts
role what's the knowledge engineer's
role yeah okay so let's be a little
specific the human expert right they
have to know all of this stuff but they
don't know how to put it into this form
right so the knowledge in Judea and this
is where there was one mark first saying
that about the expert a two marks for
further knowledge a GD really because
that was where most of the
your understanding of the XO system wars
they have to double what now to talk to
this expert and understand all of this
and get it from you know get out of
their head basically because you know
often experts if you're good at
something you might not have all of this
studio laid out in a logical sort of for
you just know what are the things you
should look for right but the knowledge
engineer is going to get all of this
down in written form okay and the
secondly they're going to convert all of
that into code right they're going to
put it into a form which the expert
system can understand which the human
x-ray we wouldn't really expect them to
do okay so like I said that question was
done really well which offset how badly
the last part of a question if it
arrives okay so let's uh let's work
through this one and and yeah we need to
spend some time with this doing a
particular interview the system
determines that a security license
should be issued okay so just pause
there we automatically know a whole
bunch about the applicant right who's
going through this particular interview
on the basis of this first sentence okay
we know that because a security license
does get issued they meet all the
criteria is that make sense because I
like they wouldn't have gone to license
okay so keep that in your head now
describe the process information
processes occurring as the inference
engine backward chains okay that's
really important and reaches its
conclusion with reference to the
original knowledge base alright let's
let's do that go through that one step
at home now on it says with reference to
the original knowledge base so that's
the table right so you had to refer to
some specific rules you had to talk
about yeah then it was looking at this
ruler than that rule in this rule so if
you didn't if you talked about in vague
terms a lot of you just said it looked
at the rules okay that wasn't that
wasn't really with reference to the
knowledge base so I couldn't you didn't
demonstrate understanding of the way the
knowledge base worth it backward chains
okay so I was looking for you to get the
right order that it was going through
the steps okay because I'm back rotating
for treating the differences or on using
the same steps but you started from a
different
starting point and lastly describe the
processing information processes and I
capitalized it there to try and make it
obvious to you right what part of the of
an expert system gets processed process
with a capital P I'll think about what
are the what are the parts of an expert
system to remember we already know this
knowledge base what are you other
component good what else if its engine
already got refer to the question what
else it's more explanation if it is a
terrible bunch of a producer okay now
think about this right does the question
have anything to do with the explanation
becasue go back to a question have
anything to do with the explanation
mechanism
Ed's up move doesn't have anything to do
with how does the system justify the
decision is making doesn't say anything
about why does it have to explain those
kinds of things the excitation mechanism
is completely irrelevant to this
question okay so if you if you spent
some time talking about it that was nice
but it did a there was a part of
answering the question ok now the
inference engine is it related yes it is
but in what way is there any processing
that is done on the inference engine
what is processing mean again yeah
there's this alteration of actual Dada
right you're mucking around with
something ok now the inference engine
after it's been written by the knowledge
engineering constructed and tested and
it works you don't muck around with it
right it doesn't get changed it doesn't
get altered it doesn't get processed
right so we're going to refer to it but
only in them in so much as it's part of
the it's what's doing the backward
chaining ok so we're not going to talk
about how it's being processed okay all
right now what about the knowledge base
what about the knowledge base is it
being processed is it being changed no
it's not because you know you don't you
don't change this thing um if the
process of actually doing an interview
right you change it when you want to do
things like this when you want to add
extra conditions in or something like
that right but otherwise it stays the
same through the through the whole
interview ok so this thing doesn't get
process either alright do ceará I'm
going and the question didn't talk about
the database of fact I didn't name it
but what it says something's being
pushed that something's being updated
also changed this has to be here right
so if you didn't refer to you didn't
have to actually say the phrase database
of fact ok but if you didn't talk about
the data it was getting changed like for
example the conditions and what was
meant and what was true not then
actually is all true then you're
trouble okay you did demonstrate
understanding of what processing is
happening in an expert system okay all
right now it was five bucks because it's
a it's quite a long question to answer
but instead of so instead of writing it
all out because we're just take me
forever it'll be quite important for you
to watch me actually write it up I'm
just going to talk you through well how
we do it here okay so backward JD where
am I going to start if I backward
chaining ya think about the arm think
about the decision tree for a second
okay if I start from age go through
these conditions and end at an action
okay what kind of logic is that is this
backward or forward chaining this is
forward cheating right how can you tell
by the way yeah yeah if you remember the
difference between backwards and
forwards training-wise do you start with
data right and then move to a decision
or do you start a decision and then
think about the data that's relevant
okay so this is forward chaining this is
classic for change you just look through
all the data and then eventually you'll
come to a decision ok but if your
backward chaining you don't start with
the data you start with the decision ok
so here's where you had to say the
inference engine would look at rule
number one first so this is what I mean
you had to name some rules ok if we look
at them rule on one first and it would
have to determine ok is a correct age or
conditions bet ok so first it says will
correct age how do I know what a correct
ages which rule tells you how that
answer rule 7 so after a rule one rule 7
is inspected ok and it simply is ok is a
greater than or equal to 18 right now
here's where the process who comes in ok
the database of facts gets changed I
know that at age greater than 18 has to
get in put it right because this person
will get a license at the end yes so
they can't be younger so then I say an
age greater than 80 is inputted to the
database of fans and so rule 7
is changed the status of true but it
meets this condition now ok now this
rule is finished there's nothing else in
this rule it come back it comes back to
room one and it's it's bed this
condition so it moves on to the second
one conditions map how do I know if
conditions are there it goes on to rule
too ok so rule to activates and it goes
through good references and Australian
resident so how do I know if references
are good enough which rule is being
referred to answer will fire so can you
see what I'm doing right um it's quiet
in some ways it's not hard you just have
to go through it step by step ok but you
have to know I don't want to restart go
away you just have to show that you
understand the way the logic of the
knowledge base depends on itself ok so i
would go rule five then i'd say if to
authorize referees so then i'd say well
okay how do I know there are authorised
referees go into rule six ok and so you
can see that ordered which I'm naming
the steps after you've gone through rule
six you go through and the references
and 12 months old so now this thing
right it doesn't refer to any other
rules ok so now i can say the database
of fact gets adjusted they put in the
fact you know this is the the clock
who's conducting the interview they say
yeah they look at the references they
check the date and there are there
lessons their recent ok it's not like
this person was a great guy five years
ago and now he's you know is it's an
expert or something like that so this is
fine still up today now that this
mission this condition is met you go
back to good references you say yep
that's true now you go to australian
resident which is rule number three ok
so you can see how i'm naming the rules
and i'm going through it in the right
order that's crucial that's how you know
it's backward forward training ok let's
trade resident valid document cited and
does that make sense eventually you get
to the fact that both of these
conditions get met all of these rules
been taken into account and so finally a
security license is issued ok so the
database of fact is adjusted to show
that that rule number one has been
change to the status of true not false
okay so I went into a lot of detail
there because we did creep disastrously
on that on all of these aspects that
I've eventually right look there we go
people people did not talk about the
processing that got happened like a lot
of that happened that take that to
replace a lot of people didn't talk
about the database effect at all they
didn't talk about backward sure he
wasn't too bad but the order was just
sort of people had all random sort of
there wasn't much order to it okay so it
wasn't clear whether it's forward or
backward and there was very little
reference the actual knowledge base in
the rules that were involved okay there
was I think I'm count less than one on
one hand is the number of people who are
actually referred to specific rules and
how they related to each other okay so
does that make sense that's how the
question like this get answered decided